でも第一次禅定の場合は邪具は生まれないとは思いますけどね
これはもうなかなか私にも言いにくいし
人間には経験一つしかないんだから
同じことをまた繰り返して経験してみようかと言ったっても
それは不可能であるし
こちらでも同じことを言おうとしているだろうと思います
このジャワナの見え決まり
言いたい時はどんな心決まりますかというと
やっぱりこの禅定の安息の心で決めるんです
暗所上が者具だったら即行心も者具
暗所上が器具だったら即行心も器具と似ていなきゃダメですから
それだったら我々はどこで判断するかというと
第1 禅定は器具か者具かと
ということは  第1 禅定は器具でしょう
それだったらもう即行心は器具であることはもう決まってるんです
もう変化できません で
次のまあまあだから次のポイントは
もし阿羅漢になった人がヴィパッサナー瞑想して阿羅漢になったと
でもサマーディ瞑想もやってみたいんだと
なぜかというと このサマーディ瞑想のいいところがあるんです
ずっとこの欲世間から心を離れて
なんか全く違う世界にいられるんですね
だからものすごい楽なんです
たとえ阿羅漢になっても
普通の心でそれから生きてるんだから
もうすごい苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけないんです
煩悩はないだけで 体が例えば病気になったらどうせ痛いし
食べ物が当たったらそれを体は痛いし
人々と喋ったり説法したりすると体が疲れるし
そういうのはあるんです
それでまあ面倒くさいんだからね
楽にしたいなと思ったら禅定を作らなくちゃいけない
サマーディをやらなくちゃいけない
でもサマーディをしても
その人のとっくに悟っているんだから
別に何の意味もないんだよ
サマーディの ただサマーディの心を作っただけ
その場合は唯作心と言うんですね
ただ心が生まれただけ
カルマはない 生まれ変わったら結果得ることはない
サマーディ作った人が死んじゃったら必ず梵天に生まれ変わっちゃうんです
欲界に来ないんです ですから欲界に嫌われて
人間の世界に嫌われて
嫌って梵天に行きたいという人が瞑想してサマーディをして梵天と一緒になっちゃうんですね
その人々には煩悩があるんだから
どこかに生まれ変わりたいと
悟った人にはそういう煩悩はないんですが
心はそこを成長することはできるんです
で こっちがわかりやすい例で言うならば
仕事として運転したい人も
人が教習所に行って運転習うと
その人免許証を取ったところで何しますかというと
仕事探しちゃうんですね
仕事を探して それからプロの運転手として仕事をして
それで食べてるんです
まあ普通にも別に自分には仕事があるし
もうお金もいっぱいあるし
もうやることないし じゃあ試しに運転免許でも取ってみようかなと思って
もう一人の人が同じ教習所に行くと
行ったらその人もちゃんと訓練を受けて免許証を取ると
取ったら俺にも免許証あるんだと思うだけで
別に運転はしない たまにどこかドライブに行きたい場合は運転するかもしれませんだけど
それで終わっちゃうんですね
ですからそんなような差なんですね
大体免許を持ってる人々がたまに車を運転したりするんだけど
それは楽しいんだからやるだけで
じゃあこれで食べていきますという気持ちはまるっきりないでしょうね
運転で食べてる人々はまた別で
その人にとってはそれは楽しみでも何でもなく
自分の仕事なんですね
その人は普通の人よりは上手かもしれませんだけど
サマーディの場合も サマーディを得て何かしたいなと思う人々が梵天に生まれ変わる
阿羅漢になった人が まあ私も試しにやってみようかなと思って瞑想サマーディ瞑想すると
第1 第2 第4 第5 とか
そういう禅定が生まれるんです
生まれるんだけど ただ禅定楽しみだけであって
それによって他の何か得ようという気持ちはない
ただの唯作心 ですから
阿羅漢になった方が聖者が瞑想を始めたら
サマーディ瞑想を始めたら
また同じくハリカンバウパチャーアヌロマゴートラブーという心が生まれて
すぐに禅定の心が生まれる
でもこれ全部唯作心なんです
阿羅漢にとっては善も悪もないんです
ですから この即行心はいつ有為下品になるかというと
サマーディが有為下品であるならば
即行心も有為下品 こんな決まってることをデバスバス言わなくたって
例えば即行心が専心でサマーディだけ有為下品になりっこはないんです
もうあらかじめなってるんだから仏通専心しか生まれませんし
その専心も有為下品であるってことは決まってるんです
だからそこら辺のこの言い方は良くないと思います
このテキストで それからこのタダーランマンに対して
この可笑に対してはもうずいぶんうるさいことを言ってますけど
まああの それほど まあそれは飛ばしてもいいと思います
ここら辺ちょっとおかしいんですよ
この百十三ページのこの百分による道というところも
例えば怒りの心が心の即行心が生まれたら
可笑は遮後だと それはわかります
で 有分心も遮後だと言ったって
有分心また人に決まってるんだから
有分心は変わらないし
そこら辺はまあ私は大体飛ぶんです
それからこの百十五ページから進みます
そうしなきゃ前の説明しちゃうと色々混乱するかもしれませんし
このアビダンマの用語はむちゃくちゃ覚えていないと私の説明はわからなくなっちゃうし
ですから百十五ページにこのジャワのニヤマ
即行の決定というものがあるんです
もう時間ですね 私にももう一つ講義があります
今日はまあしょうがない
で 即行心はだいたい七つ生まれるということはまあ決まってるんですね
で 七つか六回も生まれる可能性あるんだと
でも人が死ぬ瞬間 んで心-- あの即行心は七つとは思われません
それからお釈迦様がこの神通力を行うときも
即行心は一つ二つで終わっちゃうんですね
だからもう恐ろしい速さで
もうどんな人間にもできない速さで認識が働いていっちゃうんです
で サマーディ作るとかなり時間かかっちゃうんです
お釈迦様には瞬間にサマーディ作って
それをやめて次のサマーディに入ることはできるんです
それにはこの即行心七つ七つ使っちゃうとできないんです
で そういう特別にお釈迦様だけにあった能力はあるんですね
死ぬ瞬間で即行心七つ生まれないのは
その時は心が弱いんだからなんです
じゃあそこら辺でやめておきましょう
で  [背景音]